[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to another episode
of "VM End-to-End," a show
where we have a VM skeptic
and a VM enthusiast
come together
to hash out all things
Google Cloud VM-related.
Brian, thanks again for coming.
I'm excited for this episode.
BRIAN DORSEY: Money
matters to everybody.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah, exactly.
Last episode, we
said, we're going
to have to talk about cost.
What this is going
to do to my pockets?
And that's what I want to know,
because before this episode,
I actually went and
filled out a spreadsheet.
I listed all of my resources--
all of my machines and CPUs.
And then I went and saw how much
it would cost to just put that
over in the cloud.
And--
BRIAN DORSEY: I know
where this is going.
CARTER MORGAN: --I
don't know if you're
going to be surprised by this.
It was way more expensive
than just running it on-prem.
What's up with that?
BRIAN DORSEY: So
that does happen
when you do a straight
one-to-one mapping sometimes.
And I think the key thing
is where Cloud usually
saves the most money
is through having
high utilization of the
machines you're actually
running at the time and changing
what you're running over time.
So my question back
to you is, how did you
decide on those machine sizes
to put on the spreadsheet
and do the math out from?
CARTER MORGAN: I will be honest.
I sized it based on if I was
purchasing a machine today,
I would need it to last
three to five years.
So how much RAM
do I need to have
for it to be still relevant
three to five years from now?
How much space?
And then also, I
need these machines
to be able to handle peak
workloads that I might not
always be operating at.
And so I had to be able to
have CPU and RAM that could
handle the worst-case scenario.
BRIAN DORSEY: So most
days, they're probably
way overspecified.
And then occasionally,
they're hitting their limits.
And that's--
CARTER MORGAN: Yes.
But they were cheaper
than the Cloud--
you know what I mean?
They were cheaper than the
Cloud VMs I was talking about.
BRIAN DORSEY: That's where the
bulk of the savings-- and I
think there's some other
stuff I want to hit.
But the bulk of the
savings come from this pay
for what you use concept.
CARTER MORGAN: Pay
for what you use.
I hear this.
I hear this all the time and
I don't quite understand it.
I just interrupted and you
were going to explain it.
But I just hear
this phrase so much,
and so I really want to know.
I really didn't mean it.
BRIAN DORSEY: So the simplest
is turn the machines off
when you're not using them.
But I think it also is
a little bit confusing,
because usage is a broad term.
And we use it for actually
two different concepts
in Google Cloud.
There's the pay for
specific work done.
So if you're using a
cloud storage bucket,
actually saving an item in
the bucket or retrieving it.
And then there's this
sense of reservations.
So the way most of the
billing for the VM works is it
starts when you make the
API call to turn it on.
And when we call to turn it off,
that's when the billing stops.
So it's this reservation.
CARTER MORGAN: So when they
talk down to the second,
pay for what you
use, that's what
they're saying in that case.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
And we actually do
bill to the second
with a 10-minute minimum.
So when you do the math out for
a way overspecified machine,
it's going to sit at 5% usage
or something all the time.
And all that extra is wasted.
And that's what we want to
avoid to save the most money.
The other thing, though--
CARTER MORGAN: That does
make a lot of sense.
BRIAN DORSEY: --that I'm
going to jump on a little bit.
So when you just do
the spreadsheet out,
you're only focusing
on the computers.
And there's a lot more to it.
So you have people's
time to set those up,
to troubleshoot them when
something goes wrong,
to respond to failures
that might happen.
You maybe overbuy
for redundancy.
You've got to hook
them up to a network.
You probably have some security
boundaries you want to enforce.
Maybe you buy a load balancer.
All this extra stuff
that is actually
baked into the
cost at the hourly
or the per-second
rate of a cloud VM.
CARTER MORGAN: Yeah.
That really does
add up over time.
And that's true.
If I had to factor
in people-hours
and all the rest of this,
those costs in my spreadsheet
would go way up.
Something I am
concerned with, though,
because it seems like a cloud VM
is a different mental paradigm.
It's a shift in how we
have to think about it.
So what are the hidden
costs or gotchas
that come up when
people are switching
from on-prem to cloud?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
And a lot of moving
parts, and we're
encouraging you to
turn things on and off,
and maybe run test environments,
and this other stuff.
You hear stories about I've
got this charge running
on some other service.
I don't know where
it comes from.
That I think we've got
a pretty good solution
for in Google Cloud.
So we have a concept
of a project.
And all of the resources
live in this project.
And so if you
delete the project,
all the resources will get
turned off and not charged
for in the future.
CARTER MORGAN: I want something
like that for all of my--
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh my gosh.
Me too.
CARTER MORGAN:
--subscriptions in life.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN DORSEY: That
would be amazing.
There are some kind
of not obvious things
that I think are
worth paying for
or that you might not think
to include in your estimates.
So the worth it side,
I think it's worth
looking into the
support options,
because there's some really
highly trained, really awesome
folks on our support team who
can help you out when things
get into troubleshooting mode.
So I think that's
worth thinking about.
The other one that
I think really
can be a surprise
is network traffic.
So inbound networking is all
free and part of the deal.
But you do pay for going out of
the cloud, what we call egress,
of bandwidth.
And it's different
depending on where it goes.
CARTER MORGAN: So
different zones
might cost more, or from
one zone to another zone
in another region--
BRIAN DORSEY: So
crossing regions
costs a little bit of
money, not as much.
And then getting out
of cloud entirely--
so if you've got traffic
going to the United States,
or to Asia, or Europe, there's
a slightly different rate
for each.
CARTER MORGAN: It
seems like there's
a lot of different
moving pieces and parts.
You touched on that earlier.
How do I actually
go about estimating
what it's going to cost for me,
or how much of machine type 1
I'm going to need and machine
type 2, different tiers
of service?
How do you go about
estimating that?
BRIAN DORSEY: I have to,
unfortunately, admit this
is actually hard to do, partly
because there are so many
moving pieces.
And a straight-up
multiply it out
in a spreadsheet is
a way overestimate.
So how do we get more accurate?
One of the things we
can do-- if you've
got a really good
understanding of a workload,
we have an online
calculator that
includes all of our discounts
and all the different services.
And you can fill it
all in, and you'll
get a solid estimate of
what that would cost.
Unfortunately, it's
difficult to get
to that level of
knowledge of a system
without running the system.
And so what tends to
be the most accurate
is to run a mini
version of the system,
and log and monitor
that, and of do a spike,
for either a shorter amount of
time or with fewer machines,
just to see what is actually
all of the moving pieces.
And then you can use that as a
base to multiply and estimate
from.
CARTER MORGAN: That actually
makes a lot of sense.
I guess one thing
I'm curious about,
though-- because it makes sense
that if I'm only spinning up
machines that I'm
mostly utilizing,
I'm going to save
money in that way.
What about if I
have machines that
are running for a
long time, though,
or if I'm close to utilization?
Because it seems like
this is a rental type
model, where I'm renting,
renting, renting,
and never really owning.
Are there any savings
related to that.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
There's a whole bunch.
And I think the main thing is--
and you're a Kubernetes guy.
Why do containers exist at all?
I think it's to try to get high
utilization on the host machine
so that you get the most work.
And the container keeps
each app in its own space
so you can put a lot
of different things
on the same box, and run the
box at 80% instead of 5%,
things like that.
So we have an extra
tool in Cloud VMs where,
instead of trying to fit a
lot of pieces in one box,
you can change the
shape of the box.
So if you have a workload that
is very RAM-intensive or very
CPU-intensive, you can change
the shape of the machine
to fit your actual process.
CARTER MORGAN: I
actually like that a lot.
I'll throw in a random example.
But if I was packing
a backpack, it's
like, if I can change the
shape of the dividers,
I can fit more in
instead of trying
to find odd-shaped items
to fit into the backpack.
So that's one of the benefits
you get in the Cloud.
And that still lets you pay
less, because again, you're
utilizing less space overall.
BRIAN DORSEY: And those shapes--
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
that makes sense.
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah.
CARTER MORGAN: That
doesn't really--
well, I was going say
that doesn't really
touch on the rental model,
like this idea that we're
paying a lot, but we're never
really owning the machine.
BRIAN DORSEY: To address
that more directly, it
is always going to be a rental.
But when you're using it for a
long time, it's more efficient.
And so we automatically offer
what we call a sustained use
discount when that is the case.
So if you're running
the same kinds of CPUs--
doesn't even need to be the same
machine, the same kinds of CPUs
over time, we'll
automatically give you
a discount of up to around 30%.
And then if you know--
so there's a big deal there.
And then if you know you've
got that base workload
over a long period of time, you
can essentially kind of reserve
that, a committed use discount
to pay ahead, and get an even
bigger discount on that.
CARTER MORGAN: OK, so there's
a lot of savings there.
There was another one--
I did a quick scan.
I did a quick look, and
this one blew my mind.
I do not understand it at all.
They were called
preemptible VMs.
Can tell me about those?
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
So if you imagine--
we were talking
about this Tetris problem,
trying to fit things in.
You've got a data
center-scale version of that.
And so if we can run machines
in the corners, it's useful.
So but we need to stay flexible.
So we offer a machine,
preemptible type
or a preemptible mode,
basically, that fits in there.
So if you know that you have
a workload that is either
relatively quick or
that can be restarted,
you can run it there and run
it at like a fifth of the cost.
CARTER MORGAN: A
fifth of the cost?
BRIAN DORSEY: Like
20% of the cost.
So the only difference
between a preemptible
and a regular machine is
that it's guaranteed never
to last more than 24 hours.
It will stop.
And it might turn
off at any moment.
So you have to be able
to restart your work.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
But for the types of
workloads that would fit for,
that's a huge savings.
I guess another thing
I'm really interested in
is on that model--
again, I'm used
to maybe using 5%.
And now we're moving
towards using 80%.
What happens if I'm
not using anything
at all for a little
while, or I don't actually
have any activity going on?
BRIAN DORSEY:
That's even better.
So if you stop a
VM, you only pay
for the disk usage and
nothing for the actual CPU,
memory part of it.
So you can stop it and then turn
it back on whenever you want.
And you can even do
that on a schedule.
So if you know
three days a month,
this machine needs
to be working,
you can schedule
that ahead of time.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh wow.
OK, then what about for
things that I don't--
I can't predict, per
se, a spike in traffic
for some sale or
something that went on,
some celebrity
mentioned my product.
Is there any way to handle that?
BRIAN DORSEY: So the
most common pattern
there I think is groups of
machines that are running
the same image
that work together
and all live behind
a load balancer.
So you've got traffic
coming into one place,
and it gets spread across
a couple of computers.
And then you get more traffic,
and you add a few more
computers.
Less traffic, you turn them off.
So the managed instance
group can actually
auto-scale the size of the
group based on load or metrics
that you define.
CARTER MORGAN: And
again, you're only
paying once those VMs startup?
BRIAN DORSEY: They're
on and they exist.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow.
So to recap, because this
actually seems really cool,
and it's changed the way I
think about pricing and cost,
because before, I was buying
for the next five years or so,
plus playing for people
to manage things,
was paying for networking
and all the rest of that.
And now with the cloud, it
seems like you're really
renting or buying for the
next five seconds or so.
What am I using right now?
OK, let me try to
only pay for that.
BRIAN DORSEY: I agree 100%.
CARTER MORGAN: Does that
sound like a good recap?
OK.
So then, you know what?
I kind of want to go and
actually try this out.
I want to take my
spreadsheet, and I want to go
and, based on the
different types of work,
I want to see what
discounts I can get.
Any tips or next steps
that I should take?
BRIAN DORSEY: Yeah, go do that.
Start some VMs and
see how they work.
But I want to let you
know there's actually
a free trial and a free
tier to help you do that
and experiment with Cloud.
CARTER MORGAN: A
trial and a tier?
Please explain.
BRIAN DORSEY: So it's
a little confusing.
They're both Ts, and like
free trial, free tier.
So everyone new to Google Cloud
gets a $300 coupon, basically,
to use in 90 days for any
service, any part of Cloud
that they want to use it on.
And in addition to that,
there's a long-running tier.
So the first little bit of usage
for about 20 different products
is free, and then only
after that do we charge.
And included in
that is a small VM
that you can leave running
as long as you want.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh wow.
That is really cool.
I'm going to have to go
and check some of this out.
Brian, thank you so
much for coming in.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
CARTER MORGAN: If you're
listening at home,
step number 1 is go try out the
free tier or the free trial.
And anyone else, if you've been
using Google Cloud for a while,
if you know about
pricing and cost,
share some tips in the comment
below for other folks that
maybe aren't as experienced.
I'll go through and read that.
I think that'd be
really helpful.
Thanks for watching.
And thank you again, Brian.
[MUSIC PLAYING]